all right another day another
intensifying scandal for governor andrew
cuomo of new york because breaking
tonight
the new york times has now reported
another accuser has now come
forward as aid alyssa mcgrath is now
accusing cuomo of making
suggestive remarks gazing down her shirt
asking about her lack of a wedding ring
calling her and her co-worker
quote mingle mamas and now mcgrath is
the first current aide to speak publicly
about these harassment allegations
cuomo is yes denying these allegations
we'll have a lot more straight ahead but
also developing tonight
accuser lindsey boylan remember the one
that came first
and came forward with a new allegation
that cuomo said
that he would quote mount her
if quote he were a dog oh boy
now in that same interview with ronan
farrow boylan
also slams hillary clinton for her
silence and her refusal to condemn cuomo
for what is now a growing number of
accusations that suggest
a predatory pattern of behavior now as
pharaoh writes in
the new yorker quote clinton boylan
tolmie
was the great hero of my life she said
that was no longer the case
there's no way you don't know who this
man is
if you've worked with or around him for
decades
she added but remember the
accountability for governor cuomo
should have come a long time ago with
his nursing home cover-up
and group home cover-up because breaking
tonight the new york times also
reporting that the fbi
is now probing whether or not the cuomo
administration gave false information
false data on nursing home deaths to
the department of justice amid their
inquiry last summer
this story is now intensifying by the
hour it all started with the march
25th 2020 order despite early warnings
from the beginning and then over the
summer cuomo and his team
they saw very early by june and then
their cover-up started
in other words the true extent of the
death in nursing homes
and then his staffer admitted on a call
that they were fearful of a federal
investigation
that would be called corruption
obstruction you pick the word that fits
for you
certainly a failure of leadership and
the victims their families they deserve
so much better
here with reaction the host of candace
candace owens
uh all right candace this is a real
serious issue so all of this is now
culminating into one big movement
where's that headed
yeah you know i do want to point out one
thing that i think is sort of getting
lost in all this noise which is really
remarkable to point out about cuomo
at the same time that he's instructing
his staff to bury the death count and
instructing people to go into these
nursing homes
um he's also pending a book okay he's
pending a book a self-congratulatory
book to himself
and making money off of saying i am the
cover leader is positioning himself as
if he's going to run in the future for
president states
there's something rather maniacal about
that is there not
to say hush keep us on the hush we don't
want anybody to know this we want to
keep it under the hush because we don't
want
any federal investigation at the same
time that you're accepting emmys and
awards for press
briefings and you're also pending a book
so let's not
let that get lost he's in a bad state
right now we know that
it's going to see be remarkable to see
whether or not he
steps down because he seems to be
holding on i'm not sure what for
everyone's throwing him under the bus
except of course
for the clintons right yeah of course
okay
now overall do you see that as
obstruction
in other words our knowledge is it was
the march 25th executive order for the
nursing homes
okay the numbers showed in june that a
very high number of nursing home deaths
had occurred
then we had the admission by a cuomo
staffer
that they wanted the health department
to hide those numbers
because they didn't want them to be
found by the department of justice
that was the beginning of the cover-up
when at that point the responsible thing
to do would have been to rescind the
order
what do you see from a legal standpoint
yeah i mean from a legal standpoint
absolutely it's an open and shut case in
terms of obstruction but
open and shut cases have never gotten
democrats in trouble
you know that i know that right so at
the end of the day
maybe he gets a slap on the wrist and he
gets to go off into the silent i think
at
worst he's going to have to step down
he's not even doing that now so
you know i'd like to be optimistic i'd
like to believe in the process i'd like
to believe
uh that the fbi will will take the
necessary steps to make sure
that he never gets any power in his
hands ever again but i'm never i always
find myself
shocked that they can get away with so
much democrats
um and and yet there seems to be no
consequence for any of the actions that
they do
okay and that's that's the main thing
now could you imagine if
any of this was under donald trump's
watch what would the media be doing and
saying no
no i'm kidding obviously that's the
answer
no i'm actually not kidding but i have
to ask
what would they be doing if this i mean
there's so many questions of what they
would be doing
what if trump fell up steps today you
know i mean what i mean every single
thing that trump did was under scrutiny
all the time they never
let up on their pressure campaign and
they were falsely accusing him the whole
time
they had no evidence of anything that
they were accusing trump of they just
thought if we say it enough times it's
true if we create enough pressure
he has to go away and and they never let
up not once and you're not seeing that
same treatment in the media right now
when it comes to cuomo you're not seeing
uh that same treatment with all of these
accusers coming left and right you're
not seeing that resound renunciation
uh that we we saw for trump when there
was absent any evidence you know so
there still seems to be and yes a lot is
going on a lot of crews are coming out
to speak
against cuomo but you are not seeing uh
the vicious campaign
that they let against donald trump being
treated and executed the same against
governor andrew cuomo and we need to see
more of that all right candace thank you
as always for being with us we
appreciate it